je vais vous dire ce qu'il vous
manque docteur
Jones pendant que vous meniez votre
petite
enquête je vous manipulais
vous vous
espériez peut-être trouver un sens à
votre misérable
vie au lieu de finir
ici mort et oublié dans les sables
[Musique]
d'Afrique
mythe
histoire deux façons différentes de voir
le passer
des millénaires de réflexion et de
croyan dispersé
enterr qui
attend tu ne peux pas continuer à fuir
tes problèmes
Indiana je vais me gêner
au cours des
siècles l'humanité a bâti des lieux
d'une importance spirituelle
capitale si on relie tous ces sites
anciens à travers le monde on obtient un
cercle
[Musique]
parfait
j'ai déjà eu affaire à
ces
croyez-moi c'est pas de T REP très bien
voyons si vous arrivez à suivre comment
ça si j'arrive à
[Musique]
suivre
patron des anges
déchu protecteur
du
circouous le cercle
[Musique]
ancien tu sais de quand dat ce
vase
[Musique]